Don't die okay
Pew: Don't die okay?
Blue: I'll try
I'll try
We're all going to die instantly
Yellow: We're all gonna die instantly
Pew: No-no-no-no--trust me I'm-
No no no trust me, I'm super good at this game
I'm super good at this game
Yeah I'm pretty good too, sometimes
I, I think I'm better than you
[Y: on occasion] P: I think I'm be- I think I'm better than you
[Y: Well I] B: I got killed by Shroud the other day so...
I got killed by Shroud the other day, so
Y: Oh really? Congrats--
I I killed Shroud 5 times
Pew: I've killed Shroud five times
*awkward silence*
B: Yeah, him, Justin, and Dr. Disrespect
(Background Music)
Boot camp it is
Sorry, we're not homosexual
Orange: yeah sorry we're not homosexuals
Are you discriminating?
Pew: are you just [dialog]
Yeah, I am
Wow!
P: wow
Oh ****, oh no, oh no no no don't say that
P: oh s****--no-no-no-no don't say that
[inaudible]
Green: bro, oh my god--
G: I was reloading it, and [then] I got wrecked
G: by somebody
That's what a gay person would say
P: That's what a gei person would say...
[laughs]
*pew pew*
Alright green, keep crawling
P: alright green-- keep crawling
Y: aw there's two people
I'm... Ay stand still, what the **** are you doing
P: Kay, aye-- STAND STILL.
P: what the f**** are you doing?
Sorry
G: fine
[gunshots]
Can you stand still?
[chuckling]
I'm trying to fix you, oh my god you
[guns shots directed at Pew]
P: Oh my god you fu-- *Christian Channel*
Hey
P: aye
Y: whaddup
'Sup Pewds
O: sssup pewdzzz
Oh my god, we have to win now
P: Ohhh Myy Goddd
P: we have to win now
O: How do you know? *idiot*
How do you know?
P: HOW DO I KNOW??!! *c'mon man*
How do I know?
O: How do you know we're gonna--
Oh!
O: OH
I miss heard you my guy, my bad
O: my bad
P: [chuckles]
(Chuckling)
I can see the future
P: I can see the future
P: that's why
That's why
Are we going to win?
O: Are we gonna win?
P: I mean-- I just said it
I mean I just said it
(Laughing)
What if we don't?
O: What if we don't?
P: you pick-- well, it WILL happen alright?
Well it will happen alright, don't worry about it
P: Don't worry about it--
Just pick where we're landing
P: ju-pick-just pick where we're landing
(Laughing) Ok
O: is that not your style?
Is that not your style?
P: [chuckles] yeah yea-- no it's just-- [chuckles]
Yeah, no (Laughing)
That is how you win the game dude
P: THAT is how you win the GAME dude
O: It's the BIG BRAIN STRAT
It's the big brain strat
P: [chuckles]
That's thinking outside the box
P: That's thinking outside of the box
(Laughing)
O: yeah [chuckles]
P: I like it
I like it
Are you, no your not. Your not really Pewds
O: Are you- no you're not
O: you're not really Pewds?
P: Nahh-- I just sound like him
No, I just sound like him
O: yeah a lottt
Yeah, alot
O: feels bad man
P: [chuckles]
(Laughing)
Nah I'm just kidding, its me.
P: Nah I'm just kidding-- it's me
O: Nahhh-- I don't believe you
No, I don't believe you
Alright
Low key though, where do we drop?
O: Lowkey though, where do we drop?
I'm serious, I told you this is how we win
You **** **** c'mon man, you said it
I'm dropping there i'm telling you right now
That's where the loot is
Your going to be like swimming across and get shot down
No no no there's two buildings, we get one each
just for you, pick with one do you want?
Oh, I already picked
Alright I got a Health pack
(Laughing)
That doesn't sound like the essentials
Alright, what did you get?
You didn't get a gun?
(Laughing)
I got a health pack too
Wait, where are you?
No no we both get health kits, we got health packs dude
(Gun shots)
Look at that, we're **** geniuses
I told you this is the spot
I told you!
This is the strat, what do you mean don't loot there's still a team
Wait, there's more people?
Yeah he was knocked, right?
No you killed one guy, oh ****
You tell me what you want
You really, really want
I really, really want to know
Just going through a bad Spice Girls reference there, but I guess it's too dated
Could you sing one?
Other that the, "Tell me what you want, what you really, really want" no
That was really good
(Car beeps)
Hey, can I drive?
Umm
Are you any good?
Ah, I'd like to think so
I do autocross racing when I'm not wasting my life on the internet
Show me the flips
(Crash)
(Laughing)
It's good, it's good
Alright don't die guys
I got more if you want?
Yeah
What?
Are you making dirty jokes?
(Laughing)
You catch them fast man
I don't like it, alright
I thought this was a christian server
I'm going to have to report you then
I wont report if you, promise not to make any more dirty jokes, ok?
Can you even report your own team?
Yeah, yeah, yeah you can
You can, don't, don't threaten me to not do it
(Laughing)
(Gun shots)
Dude, this guy has a **** machete dude
Oh my god, this is what you get for swearing on a christian server
Oh, look at this guy, what is he doing?
What is he doing?
(Gunshots)
Don't kill him
He's my christian slave
You sound like PewDiePie
I get that alot
Where you from dude?
China
Sweden?
China number one
(Gun shots)
He's alive, he's alive
What are you doing?
How does that all miss what the ****, how?
How?
How the F...
Oh my god
Hey, shut the *********
Ok, you cant miss this
Oh my god
Why are you laughing?
Oh my god, look at all this epic loot I got now
Gonna give me anymore tips?
No tips!
Alright
What did you, WHAT?
Dude, I can hear you
You are so dead
No, no, no I heard
No that's not what you said, you said a not christian word and I'm playing on a christian server
Can you stop, please?
Ok, I'm sorry
Alright, you're forgiven
I still have to report you though
You're a piece of trash, garbage
You're a ****
You're a...
Bag of balls
That no one wants
(Laughing)
Oh, that's true
Alpha is too far, c'mon
No, it's not
Yeah, it is
C'mon
Alright, if I don't make it
I'm going to report you
(Laughing)
For what reason?
For lying, obviously
My Mom works for this game
I'm not joking
You got to go around that mountain
Yeah, I'm not sure we can get past the mountain
No, no, no yellow said we can make it, I trust
Yellow you're so banned
(Laughing)
No, no I'm in it too, no shut the **** no
No!
Behind us!
Oh behind us
Yeah behind us
Don't worry guys, Ill save you
(Guitar solo)
I told you, I'm pro
Watch this solo dinner
Do you see this, I have five hundred kills
Stolen other people's kills
No, I'm doing all the work dude
You're dead, alright?
You can't talk
That's true
Shit got real dog
I'm fine
(Burping)
Ay, ay, no, I'm going to have to report you now
But I burped
Yeah, this is a christian server
It was like I was a dinosaur
Wait, that's a point of controversy, let's not mention those Christian
(Laughing)
Oh, my, god
Oh, don't threaten me, I will, yeah
Did you see that carry last game?
I, I left, I don't know what happened
Alright well I got
I got, five thousand kills but I died at the last one
Oh nice
Well you should have stayed, I needed the support
I'm sorry
I was busy reporting someone
Where should we drop?
Ughh, I don't know
I'm not good at making choices
C'mon man you can do it
Make a choice, we will, we will go there
No, I want to hear where NordicBlade is going
Bravo
Aw
I swayed his opinion, sorry
It was a, it was a, it was a beautifully touching speak that he gave and it really swayed my opinion
And changed my views
Don't let him influence you, c'mon man
Be yourself
Hey man, you can pick somewhere else
Let's just go to boot camp
Don't, no he's trying to sway you again
Don't listen to him
I, I was thinking like paradise but a lot of people don't like dropping hot spots
Paradise has the worst **** i've ever heard, don't ever give your opinion again
(Laughing)
I'm sorry, I'm just joking
I know, I got you man
Ugh, are you kidding me?
Green, do something green
I am
Oh, Oh, oh you're not doing anything green
Green come here